I'm going to show you an incredible
incredible video in which the mother of
a fallen Capital Riot officer refuses to
shake Mitch McConnell's hand and so do
others and they walk right by it's truly
incredible stuff to see as Newsweek
reports the mother of a fallen Capital
police officer refused to shake the
hands of two Republican lawmakers during
yesterday's Congressional gold medal
ceremony honoring the officers who
defended the capital during the January
6 Riot Gladys sicknick the mother of
Brian sicknick that was the U.S Capitol
officer who died of a stroke following
the riot did not accept a handshake
offered by Mitch McConnell and by
representative Kevin McCarthy they of
course were part of the movement that
led to the riots we have the video here
and it is
it's really something uh I'm going to
play it and as you will see
uh there are individuals here who
um first greet Chuck Schumer
and then they continue on by you see
that it is Schumer and then it is
McConnell and then it is McCarthy and
you see Mitch McConnell stick out his
hand and then you see people just walk
by you see people walk by there is
another there is Gladys picnic she walks
by and then they just continue to walk
by and Mitch McConnell's standing there
he's really you know they say Joe Biden
shook hands with the air
there is Applause
it is really uh Mitch McConnell there
shaking hands with the air now
um we actually heard from Brian's
brother Ken sicknick who was asked what
was that about why didn't you shake
hands and he says well it's pretty
self-evident but I'll tell you anyway
take a listen to this
[Music]
[Music]
whatever
cold
that Trump has on them they've backed up
the advanced or what it's meant to
wrongdoing not necessarily them
themselves but of trump all the Riders I
mean people like people like Louis
Bowman who presented the American flag
that was flown over the capitol through
January 6th Friday
and told them they were a patriot
disgusting and that's the way everything
my brother's done takes away my drug
what the heroism my brother showed
you don't think you don't think they
deserved a handshake in this context no
no
no no no what are you even saying by
shaking their hands like what it would
it really it actually doesn't make any
sense because unlike Liz Cheney they
have no idea what Integrity is they
can't stand up for what's right wrong
well it's no we're down with party first
let's give up a political career to do
it was right and try to find this route
she's she's the one Ray of Hope people
powering the whole committee that they
can show Integrity that they can show
they actually care about
the process about democracy about
everything that goes on
these guys are as low as he's got a Big
R in front of it we're going to do
whatever you think hard to argue
against what he's saying and this entire
January 6th Riot Fiasco which now is
going on nearly two years I mean we're
getting closer to the two-year
anniversary of the riots it feels like
it was just yesterday it has been
emblematic of the absolute worst of the
Republican party it's been emblematic of
we just say stuff but we don't really
have values We Stand by uh such as we're
for Law and Order
until hundreds of their supporters
rioted committing various crimes on
January 6 2021 all of a sudden they're
defending those people we are for uh
backing the blue and supporting law
enforcement until all of a sudden the
targets of their followers were Capital
police and and of course as we know with
the FBI that's also been a popular
Target as well every single one of these
stated principles and values that they
hold dear and they love to talk about
here are principles and they we can the
Constitution
well they want the Constitution thrown
out that was part of what the riots were
for at the end of the day whether
overtly or implicitly they wanted the
person who won based on the process
outlined by the Constitution to not get
the office that they won and they wanted
a guy that lost Donald Trump to be the
president
but we care about the Constitution well
not when it's inconvenient but we
support law enforcement well not when
it's inconvenient we support Law and
Order not when it's inconvenient and
then now all of a sudden they say oh
pre-trial detention the conditions these
rioters are being held in are unfair
well we've been talking about that for
over a decade on the program
and you insist oh listen if you get
charged with a crime it's probably
because you're guilty and you deserve
whatever conditions there are and you're
too dangerous to be let out on pre-trial
uh you you have to be held in pre-trial
detention
endless endless and uh now this is the
outcome and fortunately or unfortunately
or whatever it's a lesson that they are
learning but that they're not really
appearing to learn anything from